hey everyone this is Steven Weintraub
with collider I'm here at tiff with at
the cinema center at marble with
Alexander Payne uh for the holdovers um
sir thank you for coming in the studio
today
you're very welcome it's like he's just
gonna nod I'm like um listen I've been a
fan of your work for a long time and
before we get uh starting to talk about
your exceptional new movie I'm curious
for people that have never seen anything
you've directed what is the first thing
you'd like them watching and why maybe
election
probably that that remains the movie I
probably get the most compliments on
from film nerds you know I get a lot I
get a lot of sideways some descendants a
lot of Nebraska but uh
um yeah I think election's pretty good
yeah it's okay I mean you know I might
have watched it once or twice you know
what it's the only feature I've made
that's not too long is it 90 minutes no
it's not about the actual length Steve
it's about how it feels while you're
watching it oh got it and that that one
has a pretty good Rhythm to it the all
the other movies I made at some point
are just a little bit too long in a way
I couldn't avoid uh during post but
election has a very good uh metronome to
it which of your films changed the most
in the editing room in ways you didn't
expect going in yikes what a question
not chain none of the films changes a
lot but to hone the film probably
election oh wow we're going back to
there too election was over a year in
editing we had two Christmas parties in
the in The Cutting Room did you edit
that analog or digital we got that was
the first uh Avid picture Okay citizen
Ruth my first feature was on film and
then uh
we you know Ed we were still shooting
films I shot film until 2010 but uh yeah
we should cut Avid but it took a long
time to really hone and uh also I it's
the only time I've ever had to go back
and shoot something new for a movie so
Jim Taylor and I uh wrote a new ending
for it because the ending I shot
originally wasn't working it's so
interesting I okay I'm going to leave
your previous films alone and jump into
why it gets brought it up believe me I
could keep going
um so uh listen the holdovers is
fantastic thank you very much and I want
to say one of the things as like and I
know I think you were going for this but
I really felt like the film was shot in
the 70s and like just disappeared in a
vault and then I just watched it you
know if you really really think that and
you're not just giving me a compliment
and I do believe you that's really the
greatest compliment you could give me
because that's kind of what I was going
for I mean to a certain degree I've been
sort of trying to make 70 movies 70s
movies my whole
you know career but uh on this one I try
to take it one step further and kind of
to some degree create the illusion that
it had been actually made in the 70s
well talk about one of the things that I
got to tell you one movie two movies
which maybe are forerunners to that did
you see bait the English movie Bait came
out about four years ago but it was
really made by some Maniac English guy
that it looks authentically as though
had made in about 1964 but he really
went to town with it and then also uh
I'd have to cite Paper Moon which not to
compare my film to that Great
Masterpiece but there he was in the 70s
making a film that kind of looks like it
had made in the 30s
so to some degree I was doing the same
thing making a film now in the 2020s
that
basically is trying to look like it had
been the 70s let's start right from the
beginning and this is not a spoiler
because it's the how the movie opens but
you went with the uh vintage uh um like
the credits the focus the everything so
can you sort of talk about that the
beginning of the film and going for that
well I have a very good graphic artist
and we we slapped in our Banner rating
on it MP double a rating and then I had
my graphic artist design uh a vintage
Focus Features logo and a vintage
Miramax logo we just went from there and
and to their credit focus in Miramax uh
went for it yeah I was going to say I
was wondering if they were like well
they must have thought it was cool
though it looked cool they did but you
never know what these conservative
companies you know these Mega come oh no
we don't do that and you know but to
really do those things thoroughly and
you know with no tells that it really is
contemporaries uh my hats off to them so
um it's been I think six years or seven
years since you've made a film was it
always going to be this or did you think
about making something else uh instead
of this film between uh downsizing and
now I was involved in two features one I
flirted for a while with making the menu
oh wow and I went down the down the
football field a little ways with that
ultimately I bowed out and then I
prepped a film
that was really lovely and it was I was
four or five days away from the started
shooting and we pulled the plug
that was in 2019. it was a very lovely
script I had mods Mickelson and uh
shooting in about in four different
countries in seven U.S states and uh had
to pull the plug everybody's got that at
some point or another in his or her
career it seems and that was my turn
sure uh
going back into holdovers thank you for
not asking for details on that no that
because I do name names right
I I mean believe me if I had more time I
would yeah we'll talk about that yeah I
would dig but what is it listen people
have been waiting for your return of
working with Paul since sideways mostly
me I'm the one who's most been waiting
for that hi awesome man thank you so my
thing is that uh was did you ever come
close on another project and for this
was it sort of like when did you realize
oh this is going to be the one didn't
come close on another one and this one
was Taylor not tailored for Paul but
written with him in mind from the get-go
did he know that I told him early on I
said just you know this cat and I are
conceiving something for you great great
great what is it I told him the basic
poem it's great I showed him an early
draft he still liked it and we kept
hunting the draft and it just it worked
out well couldn't work out better so um
he is fantastic in this
um talk a little bit about what it's
like directing Paul on set obviously you
must have a shorthand by now but what is
it like when he is doing something great
but it's not exactly what you need how
exactly do you work with an actor or
with Paul to help craft that performance
it's usually pretty exactly what I need
oh and we have a very good
uh uh creative wavelength or something
and uh I will say that you you mentioned
shorthand it's very short at this point
is it a nod are you actually exchanging
a word you know could you it's kind of
like that like some of the people around
camera you know the key grip the gaffer
would say we've seen shorthand before
but not quite that short
one of the things about this is that you
shot um I believe no sound stages
everything was on location in
Massachusetts and and for me that added
so much to the realism because I really
felt like you're in these real places so
talk a little bit about was that a
challenging thing or was with the
Massachusetts uh tax rebate because
everyone gets you know the rebates did
that enable you to be able to do this
well those are kind of two different
questions what I like tax rebate
question and not shooting on sound
stages yeah I can't stand shooting on
stages I mean usually and most of my
movies are location movies
downsizing wasn't because it had all
that science fiction stuff in it so you
had to build things but I can't stand
shooting on stages I like to be only on
locations but usually you have to build
a bathroom or a closet or something
that's too small uh this one was 100
location and it was now folding in your
Equestria Massachusetts
Massachusetts worked out great both
because it had all the locations I
needed and uh was a user friendly for
the budget people with their uh with the
tax incentive but
I didn't really know from New England
really before baking this movie I'd
travel to New England I hadn't spent
time there and change comes slowly so it
was really uh not easy but relatively
effortless to make a period film there
to find local locations which required
relatively little modification was it
about this material that said I want to
make I want to tell this story because I
believe it was originally the person was
originally like a TV thing and then you
had an idea to make it a movie I could
be wrong about this I had this move I
had the idea for this movie for about a
dozen years never got around to writing
it
and nor did I really have the life
experience to write it authentically and
then I was submitted a pilot for uh for
a TV show that would take place in a
boarding school and the writing was
really good so I called the writer and I
said I you've written a fine pilot I
want to make it but would you consider
writing something a feature in that same
world with this idea and he accepted and
it worked out really well how long from
when you had that conversation uh did it
take to get a script that you were
really happy with yeah two or three
years something like that well that's
not that long
no
maybe shorter I don't know I don't
really remember call it two or three
years certainly by the time we were
nearing production it was two or three
years was it one of these things uh that
once you had the script uh that it was
easy to get the financing or was it one
of these things where it took a lot of
work it's never easy sometimes it's less
hard sure
and uh
this one was relatively
medium easy hearty sort of kind of for
sure had it but it was the first time I
had worked with an independent financer
it's the company Miramax which is of
course many generations removed from its
Origins and uh the guy who uh runs at
Bill block uh read the screenplay he and
I had had a history you know a million
years ago he'd wanted to finance
sideways for Pete's sake
so it worked out and it uh for for it to
be independently financed and then uh he
sold it he and CAA sold it exactly a
year ago here in Toronto uh to Focus
Features do you still get residuals for
Pinot Noir you know what I got to tell
you something
I'm the guy who's made the least amount
of money off that movie you know who's
made money the hitching post that
restaurant in Santa Ynez and a bunch of
those wine makers they continue to reap
Millions off that film what about the
guy with the thumbs over here zero
uh although when I do go up to Santa
Inez and have dinner at the hitching
post Frank who owns a place will walk me
out to my car and put a case in my in
the trunk of my car so that's nice but
um yeah let's just say farmers are
thrifty and that includes wine makers
Thrifty I really do think though that I
mean that film absolutely without a
doubt impacted the entire wine industry
and I'm sure you've heard that over the
years it never ceases to astonish me I
keep like and every time I hear that
it's like really really
uh but heck a guy's right in the former
uh LA Times not L.A times but Los
Angeles film critic Kirk Honeycutt is
writing a book on Sideways right now and
both and about its how it was made and
then its impact on the wine industry
yeah it's really something I never could
have foreseen that I just thought it was
a nice little comedy going back into uh
holdovers and also your work uh I've
spoken to a lot of people and for
example Roger deacons likes to have one
camera on set and Ridley Scott likes to
have six or eight how do you typically
like to shoot uh there we go has it
always been like that
yes
yeah
One camera sometimes two sure if you
need to to uh save perform I mean for
example in sideways the reparte between
those two actors there were times where
I had to throw up two cameras so that
they could easily overlap each other and
talk over each other and stuff like that
uh and then when you're doing when you
have a lot of extras for example you got
to throw up a bunch of cameras or but in
general I'm a one camera kind of guy
this is basically a three-hander
holdovers about three people trying to
find family
um was it was that the idea that you
originally can you sort of talk about
that Genesis of that idea and they're
all three are such distinct
personalities and people and you do a
great job in the film of establishing
all three and interweaving their story
the idea I presented to David hemmingsen
was primarily about the relationship
between the teacher and the boy and it's
he who devised the cook
so I really have David hemmingsen to
thank for that and then once he came up
with that character then it was Off to
the Races I read that Dominic who plays
the the student uh that you cast someone
locally uh you know and talk basically
talk a little bit about casting Dominic
and the fact that uh he has never acted
in a movie before it's a good story and
I'm so glad you're asking me early on in
the promotion of this film so I'm not
tired of telling the damn story because
it's going to be like a story I have to
tell a bunch of times so you get it
relatively fraction
so uh uh the I had a New York base
casting director Susan shopmaker and
bless her heart she and her team watched
about 800 submissions
because these days all you have to do is
put yourself on tape press send and but
we watch everything so of those 800 I
probably watched about 80.
did like any of them we got other parts
from that process but not the lead and
so we had talked early on about finally
just calling up the drama Departments of
the schools the boarding schools where
we'd actually be shooting and we did
that and there he was he was a senior at
Deerfield
had never been in front of a camera uh a
star in the drama club
but never been in a ham but never been
in front of a camera he just took like
took to it like a duck to water what is
it like actually
um directing someone who hasn't been on
set before
um and because it obviously is a I would
imagine it's a different skill set as a
director like Paul it's minimal but I'm
not sure how it is with Dominic thinking
about this guy Dominic Sessa is that he
is born with it and I know not I don't
know if I've actually seen that before
that
really from the first day you talk about
what do you have to
like there was a shot on the very first
day where he had to act to a piece of
tape on the matte box of the camera
which Pro actors sort of have to learn
how to do and get used to and imagine
the interlock your interlocutor over
here and he just did it
uh so Paul Giamatti and I you know told
each other that we'd kind of help him
out and give him little tips and so
forth but you only had to tell them once
what did you really it was no just
interesting to see someone genuinely
born with
and I asked him I said how how are you
able to like I mean you've never done
this before how are you able to
uh focus and act as well as you're
acting with the camera and those lights
and all those guys around you and
everything and he goes well I just don't
think about him
which is exactly the right thing you
know he's just a born Pro jerk uh with
this film talk a little bit about you
get in the editing room what did you
learn from like friends and family
screenings that maybe you weren't
expecting any did you have to tweak
anything oh you're constantly tweaking
but there was nothing major it sort of I
didn't shoot too much footage and uh
yeah
well from my buddies I sort of oh if you
put this scene a little earlier and that
was about it I mean but the script was
pretty tight and the first cuts of the
film corresponded very exactly to the
to the script and the final film is
basically the screenplay with maybe two
or three small scenes removed obviously
you do not have Marvel money to make
this so what ended up being the things
you were most nervous to be able to pull
off with the time and the schedule and
budget that you had had to go back to
the well a few times for VFX in post to
help out with the snow because we during
shooting we were blessed with a lot of
snow which was great and then put down
artificial snow
and then thought oh well we'll need VFX
to put that in I also had to put in some
VFX in post like
snow flurries sure and they couldn't get
that right for a long time so it looked
real it kept looking faky
so VFX budget and then music music's
always a big one and this is the first
time I've had like a kind of for my
level anyway gigantic music budget over
a million bucks
for both uh score and store-bought music
and uh I was happy that Miramax the
financier at the time ponied up for that
they realized it's importance so I'm
curious were there speaking of songs
how much were you
um uh picking from things you could
afford when like deciding where you
wanted to splurge you know what I mean
absolutely
so it's a constant talk to any director
and it's a constant process of like what
works and what can we afford and
sometimes it's like even find the artist
to get clearance and permission and in
this one though we skimped and saved a
little bit to be able to forward one big
Splurge which was Cat Stevens
Cat Stevens was uh the expensive one
I also like it's interesting because I
think uh some musicians would probably
and I'm of course guessing some
musicians I'm sure would love their
music to be in the movie and you'd think
would give you a discount and a thing
right
but everyone wants to get paid you know
with Cat Stevens I even it was a this
astronomical amount and uh he happens to
be uh half cypriot I happen to be of
Greek uh uh ancestry myself so I wrote a
letter to his son who runs his company
for him I said hey I'm a Greek you're a
Greek right
can't you give a Greek a break for you
25 off and it was still astronomical but
worth it the music's just you know I
tried to replace it and couldn't do it
it's just too damn good yeah I mean he's
talented no it's just unbelievable
unbelievable I want to make sure I
pronounce I don't think I can pronounce
your cinematographer's name I go brilled
thank you Michael brilda Dane
um so talk a little bit about why you
wanted to work with him and what was it
about his uh style that said this will
work perfectly for this I just like the
dude he's a really uh smart dude I had
first noticed his work he shot in Bruges
15 years ago which is a really good
movie and then
um the aforementioned uh movie that fell
apart five days before production four
years ago I had met him for that but not
hired him but liked him a lot
and also Fincher told me one time he's
the hardest working DP I've ever worked
with
so and then I sent him the script and he
just had really good thoughts and really
good comments about it
and I said it just felt right just felt
right how do you typically work with him
and let me just say too that when you
hire a department head
DP cinematographer costume designer it's
not just that person you hire it's whom
they bring with them sure and so the
quality of the crew he brought with him
was really uh terrific and also the crew
we found locally in Boston was terrific
gaffer and key grip were just great yeah
they have a a huge film Community there
now because of how much has been shot
yeah you know how do you typically like
to work with your DP and for example on
holdovers
um are you storyboarding a lot before
stepping on set never storyboarded in my
life so only on downsizing because of
the visual effects so for example you're
shooting a scene with Paul it's Monday
morning it's eight o'clock or seven
o'clock you step on set
um how do you typically figure out how
the sh what you're going to do when you
step there each scene is different
uh I think a director enters every scene
with uh concept some vacillating
somewhere between specific and vague
about how the day is going to go
obviously you feel better when it's
specific like here's what we're doing
today everybody and like map out the
shots but uh basically you just where
would people go naturally like if this
weren't a movie what would be the
realistic blocking of it and then as
Antonio used to say you make a
documentary about it you figure out
where the actors really would where
those people really would go and then
you make a documentary about a well-shot
documentary which uh I always tell
myself that because it's a very um
it it it's a soothing way to think about
you often Panic inducing process of
figuring out coverage my thing is that
like in because there's some directors
who work a lot with close-ups and
there's others who like the two shot or
you know moving camera or whatever it
may be and I'm always I mean there's no
right answer
um but I'm just curious when you choose
when do you want your close-ups save the
big heads right that goes back to film
school man we always tell told one
another save the big heads now because a
close I'm saying the obvious but a
close-up has power and meaning and when
you cut to it would if you haven't been
using it a while it has now there are a
million uh exceptions to that look at
Sergio Leone films it just starts with
close-ups it like stays in closer scope
close-ups no less but I'm kind of old
school in that way that I like to save
the big heads yeah but like I said
what's fascinating is there's no writing
I have found those sometimes when
someone uses too many close-ups they're
too close and too many shots it does
bother me because there's well and if if
done unskillfully it bleeds into you
know TV coverage because they work so
fast and it's so dialogue based that
it's basically just big heads the whole
time I read could be wrong that you and
Rhys might do an election sequel Tom
perrotta who wrote the book election has
written a very fine sequel
and Reese Witherspoon and I have talked
about it and Jim Taylor and I my
co-writer and uh about doing it but we
just haven't gotten to it yet is it
something that you think is actually
going to happen or is it one of these
things where yeah maybe I don't know yet
I don't know yet is it because I haven't
read the the book oh it's only because
it everything takes a while and I have a
couple things to do before that and
we'll just see how it falls but it would
be lovely to do I'd love to work with I
mean that's another actor I've been
dying to work with for all these years
is Reese Witherspoon and we're always
like
throwing each other flowers when we're
going to work together again
so there's a structure in place for us
to do that but I just haven't pulled the
trigger yet it's kind of up to me
but I just have some other stuff before
on on my docket sure my question though
is election everyone I mean everyone
loves that movie is there a like in your
mind is it sort of like do I want to
play in that world again you want to
make Godfather 2 not Godfather Three
right exactly exactly
so that's that's what I gotta figure out
is can it be Godfather too and not
Godfather Three yeah Matt with all
respect Mr Coppola to Godfather Three
what he said a hundred percent speaking
of copal I cannot wait to see his new
film oh my God can't wait I I am over
the moon that he has made this film it's
pretty far along and cutting right now
it'll be out next year I'm guessing yeah
I I and the fact that I mean all that
speaking of wine yeah all that wine paid
for that movie Big Time right you know
yep it's something's betting on himself
as he's always done it's I couldn't be
more excited for a film honestly also
look out there's a wonderful new book
about uh Mr Coppola coming out by Sam
Watson do you know who Sam Watson is he
wrote the book about Chinatown he just
had an oral history of Hollywood out
with Jeanine Basinger and he has just
written a wonderful new
history of zoetrope and of Coppola and
it's coming out in I think November or
November December so I'm guessing that
you've already read it I've read about
half of it and Sam Watson's a friend of
mine and there there it is the cheat
code of being a director in Hollywood as
you get sent early editions so you know
membership has his privileges besides
the American Express card what do you
think you mentioned you have some other
projects may I ask uh what are you
developing right now you know famous
last words and oh he said that at Tiff
in 2023 and it never came to be and he's
so pathetic and all that but I'll tell
you uh I don't think we're gonna say
that I've I've long Wanted let's just
say I've long wanted to make a western
okay I somehow think these nice little
comedies I've made have been are leading
me toward my true destiny I think in
Hope which is westerns is it is the
script done no you guys are writing now
or writing when there's not a straight
conceiving we're conceiving it now I'm a
huge fan of the western genre Vigo
Mortensen was in yesterday for his
Western which is an unconventional
Western breaks narrative structure
really well done
um how much are you is it a western
you've been thinking about for a very
long time and how does it fit into the
pantheon of previous westerns or are you
bringing the Alexander Payne for hell
knows no obviously it'll be as filtered
through me but uh I like traditional
westerns I like good traditional
westerns I'm so curious what your
version of Western is me too I'm curious
too that's why I'd like to make it I'd
like to know what it is yeah I'm digging
for information I'm not getting much I'm
hitting a lot of dirt
well look uh no but uh
one thing I'm doing though is not simply
watching a bunch of old westerns but
also reading late 19th century American
history in particular in Nebraska
history I'm sorry American history in
general Nebraska history in particular I
wanted to be a western set in Nebraska
central Nebraska in about the 1880s I
would say that um uh the locations there
uh are probably you can find locations
that look exactly like they are from the
1880s I hope so you know I hope
sometimes you set something one where
someplace but it actually looks more
like that used to look somewhere else so
I'm hoping we could and then you have to
deal with old damp tax incentive crap
yeah you might be in New Mexico no no
that doesn't look at all like Nebraska
uh yeah I was thinking the uh um Vigo
shot his film in Mexico the majority of
it and then other shots here in Canada
and Ontario right you know right well in
Ontario yeah
Revenant was shot in BC I think and uh
McCabe and Mrs Miller was shot BC yeah
listen I'm I am so curious so do you
think is the Western thing that the
thing that you're spending the most time
on no the thing I'm spending the most
time on right now is talking about this
movie
laughs
just starting that right you're gonna be
doing this for the rest of the year and
uh what did I do yesterday ordered a new
dishwasher from Costco
uh because the first one that came
didn't fit is that true yes 3 8 of an
inch off did you blame uh I yeah there
we go stops here right okay I was
gonna say at least you're taking
responsibility for that the thumbs right
so I've been having to do a bunch of
Life crap before really really getting
back to writing and you know it's a it's
a blessing to have a movie that people
want to you know that the studio wants
to promote you want to talk about I
that's wonderful and I look forward to
getting back to creative work well
what's interesting is that with the with
the strike uh it's mostly directors that
are getting out there and promoting you
know the work about time right exactly
do you is it something though like being
serious there's been many directors in
the past for I use a Kubrick for an
example it's just one person but there's
a lot of directors who really did not
ever want to explain their stuff and
they wanted the work to speak for it and
um and there's other directors who will
you know break down every aspect this is
a good question to end on so here's
where I I finally was able to articulate
it to myself which is
I can and will talk about process I
can't and won't talk about themes I
won't explain anything in the movie so I
think if you ask a director about how'd
you do this and how did you do that like
the logistics of it now you can kind of
talk about but oh it seems like all your
movies have disgruntled middle-aged men
in them like leave me alone man just I
don't know how to talk about that what's
good is I didn't bring up any of that
you know that we are a wonderful uh
interviewer I'm going to say on that
note that is the best I'm going to get
out of him so I'm going to say I really
I really loved your movie thanks man
thanks so much for coming in you bet and
I wish you nothing but the best thank
you